Grizzly Gore fests dance routines and
Iron Man doing laundry even the best
movies shed a scene or two in The
Cutting Room and these sci-fi Classics
are no
exception one of the most celebrated
science fiction movies of the early 80s
Star Trek 2 the Wrath of Khan may have
saved the franchise after the
disappointment of the first movie a few
years earlier but it almost included a
subplot that could have hurt its
critical
success in addition to a well-known
deleted scene involving Scotty's nephew
who was killed after Khan's initial
attack on the Enterprise the movie also
cut out an entire character Khan's
infant son in early versions of the
movie the baby is introduced when Czech
off and Captain Terrell are searching
Khan's ship the botney bay the child
would later appear with KH aboard the
USS Reliant in another deleted scene he
dies when KH accidentally activates the
Genesis device considering that the
studio decided to add a more positive
ending late in production it could be
that they felt the death of Scotty 's
nephew and Khan's infant son seemed a
bit Grim for a PG rated sci-fi family
film images of Khan's son were revealed
for the first time in a 1982 issue of
starblazer magazine but full footage of
the scenes in question have never been
released basically all movies end up
having a few scenes cut here and there
in the case of Event Horizon however
there's actually an entirely different
cut that has been lost to time this
version of the film reportedly runs over
two solid hours as opposed to the
95-minute theatrical relas and includes
far more Gore tragically the studio
didn't feel that the original footage
was worth keeping and much of it has
never seen the light of day some excised
moments include Captain Miller
discovering a loose tooth in a corridor
apparently the remains of a former
crewman most of the deleted moments
however were extended versions of
existing scenes that were far more
Grizzly than the studio or test
audiences could handle a few of these
managed to survive and a canister
containing the original film was
discovered in an old Transylvania salt
mine they eventually made their way onto
a later DVD release in a raw unfinished
form not all of the deleted sequences
could be restored though as the newly
discovered film was in poor condition
when it was
found director David Cronenberg made a
name for himself as the go-to filmmaker
for body horror thanks to early cult
classics such as video drum and scanners
in 1985 he was given the task of
remaking the 50s B movie The Fly with
Jeff Goldblum in the title role
Cronenberg crafted one of the most
gruesome mainstream science fic movies
ever made you look
bad you smell bad I've never been much
of a bther but if it hadn't been cut one
scene in particular would have made the
whole film even harder to stomach the
scene in question takes place after Seth
brundle has begun his transformation
looking for a way to reverse the effects
brundle thinks he's found the answer and
proceeds to test out an experimental
procedure on a baboon and a cat however
the process inadvertently amalgamates
the two animals and brundle is forced to
Beat It To Death topit the agony of its
own existence this moment was actually
included in early UK screenings of the
film but movie goers were so horrified
that the studio chose to cut it for wide
release it wasn't until the film's 20th
anniversary that it turned up again this
time on a deluxe Blu-ray
release there's no end to the number of
great deleted scenes in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe most of them have
found their way out of the vault in one
form or another and Marvel loves
including as many as possible on their
home video releases nevertheless for
2008's Iron Man some deleted scenes will
never be released not if Kevin feige has
anything to say about it that is in an
interview with Screen Rant Marvel
executive producer Jeremy latchum
revealed some deleted scenes were deemed
so atrocious that they'll never be made
public one of them sees Tony Stark
helping prison guard Abu do some chores
latchum revealed Tony is doing laundry
for the captors but he's really breaking
the washing machine and stealing parts
from it to build the Mark 1 suit it's so
absurd it's wild the scene was
apparently so poorly made that studio
boss fige never wants it shown Lum
continued I remember Kevin saying to me
in 2012 we can never put out aoo doing
laundry people will know we don't know
what we're doing it'll be embarrassing
if they see these scenes Starship
Troopers is a Sci-Fi Action classic from
1997 and in some ways it's also a
romance the love quadrangle between Rico
Carmen Xander and dizzy makes up a major
part of the film especially in its early
stages yet if director Paul verhoven had
gotten his way the movie would have had
an even greater emphasis on the Romantic
angle of the story in the end much of it
wound up deleted from the film after
test audiences didn't react well to the
subplot some of the scenes cut include a
moment in which Carmen deflects Rico's
sexual advances as well as a farewell
scene where it becomes clear that their
relationship is somewhat forbidden in
one later scene after surviving a deadly
attack Xander tells Carmen that he loves
her helping to reinforce that new
relationship in a Way the final film
never does the last deleted scene comes
right at the end of the film film we'd
seen the death of dizzy and Xander
earlier on and audiences may have
wondered what that meant for Johnny and
Carmen's relationship well this scene
answers that question as the pairs share
a passionate kiss just before the
credits roll if you're looking for the
best movie about a robot cop well you're
not going to do much better than RoboCop
Die Hard fans consider it the perfect 8s
action movie with not a moment wasted in
capturing the excitement of mortally
wounded cop Alex Murphy as he's
transformed into the heroic cyborg known
as RoboCop as it turned out finding
Perfection involved trimming a few
moments from the original script one of
which saw the hero cop returning to his
own grave though it wasn't filmed this
scene was included in both the
novelization and the movie's Marvel
Comics adaptation and when it came time
for a sequel RoboCop 2 director Irvin
kersner decided to make it happen this
time the sequence was intended to be
part of an early moment carrying over
from the first film's end when RoboCop
Embraces his identity as Alex Murphy
despite all the effort put into making
the scene a reality however the
graveyard visit didn't make it into this
movie either directed by the legendary
Stanley kubric 2001 A Space Odyssey is
one of the seminal works in the Sci-Fi
genre it reshaped Science Fiction with a
mix of thought-provoking drama
nail-biting suspense and
state-of-the-art special effects open
the pod bay doors
hell I'm sorry Dave I'm afraid I can't
do that for years rumors have claimed
that kubric trimmed some 20 minutes of
footage from 2001 and we finally got
confirmation when reals from the film
were discovered in of all places another
salt mine these scenes aren't exactly
the most pivotal but they do serve to
flesh out the finer details of the
mission to Jupiter some of the footage
includes extended sequences of Frank P
jogging as well as an alternate version
of the iconic opening sequence one
deleted scene sees how 9000 ending the
radio communication between the
discovery and P's pod not long before
he's killed which means a later exchange
between Dave and Hal makes a little more
sense
set in the 23rd Century The Fifth
Element introduces Mila yovich as lelu a
woman believed by an order of ancient
monks to be the key to defeating a
cosmic evil one of the fifth element's
most intriguing deleted scenes takes
place when Dallas is fing lelu and the
monk Cornelius to the airport there they
would have encountered a group of
striking alien garbage collectors taking
part in a fight with local police
remnants of the scene can be found in
the Final Cut as the airport itself is
filled with garbage piled meters high
that is never adequately explained the
airport attendant only briefly
apologizes for the mess years later a
behind the scenes featurette on the
movie's 4K UHD blu-ray chronicled this
lost moment the last film in the
franchise to feature the cast of The
Next Generation the 2002 box office dud
Star Trek Nemesis was met with a
critical drubbing on its release critics
claimed the movie was dull lifeless and
lacking in the charm of the TV series
but quite a few deleted scenes would
have gone a long way to keeping what was
lost mostly smaller character moments
between the likes of Captain Bard
commander rker and Dr Crusher while fans
have known about some of these deleted
scenes for decades one recently surfaced
that was never included on any home
video release this scene comes after
data's death aboard the Enterprise which
remains under repair we find Warf and
Jordy going through their late comrades
quds at one point data's Cat spot leaps
into warf's arms who reluctantly adopts
the felinus as own cut from the film's
initial DVD release despite the
inclusion of other moments this scene
has since surfaced online in low
resolution the biggest sci-fi movie of
the 9s Independence Day was a watershed
flick that forever changed the summer
blockbuster the movie isn't without its
plot holes however many fans have raised
questions about the virus created by
David lenson which he eventually uses to
take down the alien
Mothership Welcome To Earth some have
wondered how his terrestrial laptop
could so easily interface with
technology From Another World while
While others have scratched their heads
at how he even knew how to take down
their computer system at all a deleted
scene included on the film's 20thth
anniversary home video release would
have answered one of those questions in
this scene levenson lays out his plan to
crash the alien computer network in more
detail while he's given a tour of the
captured alien ship by Dr brackish Oaken
while Oaken admits they have very little
idea as to how the alien technology
works levenson deduces that a sequential
repeating pattern they've discovered is
actually a code that they're using to
coordinate their ships it might not be
the most airtight explanation but it
offers at least a slightly better
explanation as to how levenson brought
down those aliens before the likes of
Independence Day and Star Wars turned
the genre into Blockbuster Fair science
fiction films were thoughtful talky
dramas and The Day the Earth Stood Still
was one of the very best in this Eerie
tale an alien visitor named clat arrives
with a dire message for Earth's leaders
one that he will not reveal until they
can all gather together peacefully
escaping government custody clat two
tries to blend in with with Humanity in
order to learn why they are so
distrustful of one another but there's
one scene cut from the film that most of
the movies fans have probably never seen
in the film a detective arrives to take
clud to see a local scientist Professor
Barnhart in the original script the
detective first takes him to the police
station for questioning while there a
local man is brought in seriously
injured and it's revealed that the man
was attacked after he was mistaken for
clat two feeling a sense of guilt but
also confusion as to why people would
attack a stranger in such a manner begs
for the police to take him straight to
Barnhart though a brief scene it's one
that adds important context to clat to's
Journey demonstrating both his empathy
and Humanity's Folly Blade Runner is
pretty much a deleted scene Bonanza over
the years most of the scenes dropped
from the original release have found
their way into a multitude of different
cuts including the workprint cut the
director's cut and the so-called Final
Cut
like
tears in Ray
[Music]
yet none of these versions include the
alternate deleted opening scene that's
because it was never actually filmed in
fact it was only revealed years after
the fact in the series of story boards
first published in future Noir the
making of blade runner in the alternate
first scene detective Rick Deckard is
seen Landing his spinner on a desolate
Road he exits the flying car and enters
an empty home where he notices that
there is still a pot of soup boiling on
the stove as he listlessly stirs the
soup a large hulking man walks in and
Decker immediately shoots him dead he
then rips out a piece of his jaw
revealing the man to be a replicant and
takes off in his spinner if all of this
sounds familiar it should that's because
this original opening was used as the
intro to the sequel Blade Runner 2049
which was released nearly 40 years later
featuring some of the most jaw-dropping
action sequences in movie history
Jurassic Park is a true Blockbuster
Adventure in every way Steven
Spielberg's classic left indelible
images etched into the minds of
countless movie goers whether it's the
first s of the brontosauruses or the
clicking Talons of the Velociraptor on
that cold kitchen floor no matter how
many memorable moments the movie boasts
however there are still more that didn't
make it into the film one deleted action
sequence would have seen Alan Grant Tim
and Lex stumble upon a sleeping
Tyrannosaurus wrecks while roaming the
jungle after sneaking past the Beast
without drawing its attention they make
their way to a nearby structure where
they are able to grab an inflatable raft
from Storage they take off down the
river but just when the trio thinks
they're in the clear the te Rex bursts
out from behind the trees and tears
after them it doesn't seem as if this
sequence was ever filmed sadly and today
it exists only in storyboard
form we got
one a supernatural comedy with a pair of
former SNL Stars leading the way
Ghostbusters defied the odds to become a
pop culture icon the movie quickly
inspired a DieHard group of fans who for
decades only had a pair of films to pour
over so you can imagine the excitement
when in 201 2017 new footage from the
original movie was discovered including
some hilarious deleted scenes found in
the personal collection of director Ivan
wman the reals Discovery caused quite a
stir among Ghostbusters fans one of
these scenes was Fort De Mary a
long-known but neverseen moment in which
Ray stance has a sexual encounter with a
ghost in the final film remnants of the
scene are shown in a montage but the
full sequence has never been revealed it
opens with the Ecto one arriving at the
Fort and the team exploring the grounds
Ray puts on an old naval uniform he
finds and lays down in a bed before the
ghost of a beautiful woman enters the
room following a brief unseen sex act
that somehow did manage to make it into
the final movie Winston is seen knocking
on the door to the room wondering what's
going on given the fact that the most
risque portion of the scene actually
wound up in the theatrical cut it's
likely that the full extended scene was
simply cut for time the culmination of a
decade of stories Avengers Infinity War
brought together just about every
character in the MCU to battle Thanos
the big bad who wanted to erase half of
all life in the universe with such a
broad sweeping story to tell Infinity
War had a lot to pack in and some
reviewers inevitably felt it was a
little long and overstuffed but it could
have been worse according to thanos's
Creator Jim Starin the original plan was
actually to open the movie with an
additional 45-minute action sequence
instead of beginning with an attack on
Thor ship Infinity War would have begun
with thanos's assault on the planet
xandar he would have decimated the
entire planet in his search for the
Power Stone which is held under
protection by the Nova core in an
interview with collider Starin explained
there was a whole sequence of him
getting the first Gem and they had to
cut that out they shot it but they never
wanted to spend the money on the effects
and they didn't want the movie to be as
long as the second one was Starin seems
to feel that the filmmakers may have
regretted their decision he added they
didn't realize it was going to be quite
the hit it was another 80s icon back to
the future sends Michael J Fox's Marty
McFly hurtling Back to the 50s Marty
soon discovers that his father is a
total dwee and when his mother falls in
love with him he's forced to help his
dad get the girl to save his own
existence the film hammers home what a
loser George is by showing him being
bullied by tough guy Biff but one
deleted scene makes George look even
worse during the enchantment Under the
Sea dance at the climax of the movie
George is preparing to go through with
his plan to rescue Lorraine from a
staged encounter with Marty nervous
about acting at the right moment he
seeks out a phone booth and calls the
operator to get the time only to be
locked inside by Mark the redheaded
Class Clown who later cuts into his
dance with Lorraine with a prop Trident
holding the door closed George is then
discovered by principal Strickland who
scolds him for being a slacker but
doesn't let him out likely cut for time
or pacing reasons this sequence actually
explains why George didn't make it to
the car in time to stop
Marty most films these days include
plenty of deleted scenes once they make
their way to home video fans love to go
over the various bits of the movie they
never got to see but they're typically
Superfluous moments and it's usually
easy to understand why they were removed
sometimes though there's a scene that
leaves you wondering why it wasn't in
the movie and that's the case with a
deleted scene from Ryan Johnson's 2012
Sci-Fi Action movie Looper the film
stars Bruce Willis as Joe an aging
Hitman who uses time travel to dispose
of his targets when he's due for
retirement and his Superior sent him
back in time to be killed by his younger
self old Joe manages to escape at one
point young Joe hides out at a house
belonging to a woman named Sarah and
soon after he arrives a mafia Thug shows
up looking for him after a tense drawn
out search of the house Sarah gives the
Goon a tour of the basement where Joe is
hiding and we're sure it's going to lead
to a showdown the suspense is palpable
as the mobster stalks the room only for
us to realize that Joe is hiding beneath
the floor where he is able to escape
notice the choice to leave out this
incredibly tense scene is a real heads
scratcher following Star Trek Nemesis
the Star Trek franchise took a Hiatus
from the big screen but it came roaring
back with a new look in JJ Abrams 2009
reboots the sequel to that movie Star
Trek Into Darkness centered once again
on con this time played by Sherlock star
Benedict Cumberbatch who isn't even more
ruthless and cunning version of the
villain than that seen in Wrath of
KH this time around he is revealed to
have been manipulated by a secret Black
Ops division of Starfleet called Section
3 one led by Admiral Marcus while the
final film doesn't reveal the truth
about who is manipulating him until
later an early deleted scene almost
gives it away this moment comes in the
form of a video communication to Marcus
from Thomas herwood who was about to
detonate a bomb in London at K's behest
the scene shows Marcus receiving the
transmission in his office with herwood
informing him that the impending
destruction will be a message from con
ultimately though producers cut the
scene because it revealed a little too
much about the players involved in the
the film's commentary editor Mary Joe
Mary said we felt that it was very
important not to introduce the Admiral
in any way or tip our hand about who he
would become later on in the film we
realized to hold him back for a long
time would be more
shocking the MCU is littered with Juicy
deleted scenes but few are as
jaw-dropping as one moment cut from
Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness the film sees Steven strange
face off against Wanda maximoff who has
turned twisted and vengeful after losing
vision and her children determined to
find an alternate reality where she and
her family can live in peace Wanda
traverses the Multiverse itself and
basically Slaughters everyone in her
path Multiverse of madness has Wanda
taking the proverbial acts to the likes
of Mr Fantastic professor Charles Xavier
and blackbolt but a deleted scene
further shows just how vicious she has
really become not long after the movie's
release one of the film's artists Jimmy
simpser released storyboards depicting
the moment when Scarlet Witch arrives at
kamaraj to get her hands on America
Chavez in this unseen version though
Wanda isn't alone as she brings with her
the decapitated head of Baron
morto 1989's Bill and Ted's Excellent
Adventure is a weird and wild story that
sees the two friends and list famous
faces from history to help them get a
passing grade in School to save the
future over the years a number of
deleted scenes from the movie have
cropped up here and there and in 2020
one of the film stars dug into the Vault
to reveal yet another
excellent posting on X formerly known as
Twitter Al winter showed off images of a
sequence early in the film in which Bill
and Ted make their way home from school
the sequence would have included a
bizarre musical number that fans
ultimately never got to see winter told
Rolling Stone the opening was an almost
surreal Rock number where Keanu and I
are at a bus stop waiting for the school
bus in the morning and we start to air
guitar and Rock out and it turned into a
whole dance routine then it ends up with
us kind of getting into a skirmish with
the school jocks and you meet our
characters that way all of that stuff
was shot and none of it made it into the
film a box office Juggernaut ET the
Extraterrestrial was nominated for nine
Academy Awards including best picture
and Best Director it won best original
score and three additional technical
Awards the story of a strange alien
visitor who was befriended by a pair of
young children named Elliot and Gertie
ET remains one of the most beloved
family movies of all time yet a few
deleted scenes that have shown up over
the years might have totally changed the
tone of the film in addition to a
comedic moment that didn't make the cut
because the ET puppet just wasn't
convincing enough there's one other
scene that seems awfully out of place in
a movie aimed at kids and families
popping up decades later thanks to some
Behind The scen Stills it shows Elliot's
mother Mary lying face down but topless
asleep in bed late at night as she
Slumbers the alien creeps into her
bedroom and silently observes her though
probably intended to show ET learning
about humans the images give off a very
unsettling Vibe one that might well have
Disturbed the families in the
audience
yeah